foreign
so in 2018
a fissure started erupting on the East
Rift Zone on the big island and it was
an area that had was a lava Zone
previously and and but had since been
built over so lots of homes there was
this beautiful area called kapoho which
had amazing like hot pools and tide
pools while it's now gone unfortunately
so anyway Fisher 8 starts erupting
it splits into two and it basically cuts
off a several thousand acre Area Homes
people and this lava flow is moving very
quickly 20 miles an hour so within a
24-hour period is about three miles up
the coast like it's moving slower at the
front but like essentially cuts off this
entire area
State and feds arrive way to away
they're starting helicoptering people
and different people out people plants
pets whatever the people are holding
deer
and then a cattle rancher had been cut
off and there was still 50 plus animals
left between these two flows and you can
imagine like it looked like Mordor on
the ground like they're like sulfur was
terrible there was lava bonds the
fissure was constantly
spewing at about 100 to 200 feet oh my
God yeah so like I think I think they're
not simmer no it was 20 I think they
said it was 26 000 cubic
meters of like lava
per like minute it was it was absurd it
was like one of the fastest moving flows
they'd ever seen so anyway
a Rancher did his best job to get the
majority of his cows out
but there are 50 plus animals trapped
between these two lava flows and that's
when you saw the bat signal on the sky
it well kind of
and we had happened about a year ago to
develop the first of its kind live
capture net system that with a
helicopter you can essentially pick up
Kyle's live and get them out of there so
if you can imagine a cone-shaped net
with a 20 foot diameter frame on the
bottom and it's hanging from a hundred
foot line below a helicopter and so
helicopter is moving and this this net
is kind of flowing back and forth and
you place the net over the cowl
and then there's a switch at the top of
the cone and there's two lines and then
as the animal tries to move outside you
let the first switch goes at the top of
the cone and the net basically falls on
top of it and you just pick up the frame
and it's essentially sitting in a big
bag evenly distributed and then you fly
it out and you put this bag down and you
put the frame over and it just stands up
and walks away got it so the frame
is
basically a rectangle or a square it's
an octagon yeah yeah octagon yeah okay
got it yeah so Federal Peta everybody
gets a hold of us and says like we need
to get these cows out of here and we
were just because it was it was known at
least to some subset of folks that you
had this you developed this yeah live
capture system we were previously using
it to try and get cows out of high
elevation critical Watershed areas where
they were causing like extensive damage
do they get a hold of us they run us
through like what they want us to do of
course I had to like sit down on the
team and say like do you want to try and
rescue cows over a 20 mile per hour lava
flow and I think one of the guys turned
over and he's like we would get to be a
lava cowboy and I was like oh man
like come in who's who's gonna say no to
that one yeah and ended up like doing
our due diligence it was it was pretty
safe to do long story short we got them
all out but the first couple of days
were so intense and the very first cow
so
we're driving out there in the morning
it literally looks like Mordor like the
flow is creating its own weather system
it's raining it's dark like it's a two
mile flow so it's like lighting up the
entire area in like dark red and you're
driving towards it and you're thinking
like oh and you're passing like all
these National Guards you're just like
this doesn't seem like a great idea on
your way out yeah and we get all loaded
up in the morning the head of peta's
there like it's this huge thing there
had been so much
loss already they had lost that entire
Community hundreds of homes gone
and there had been so much loss and it's
the community was kind of starting to
gather around this idea of these things
that were left behind we could actually
get them
and get there in the morning we get all
set up
get bowed in with the pilot he had
actually never done it before but it was
the only helicopter big enough that we
could pick up those particular cows
names Calvin Dorn he's just an absolute
Legend
so we fly out first thing in the morning
like heading towards figure eight it's
fountaining 200 feet in the air like
there's lava bombs like that look like
they're going at the height of the
helicopter the cows are trapped like
right underneath it there's video there
so we can yeah put it in the show notes
oh man it's crazy and he goes to pick up
the first cow
grabs the first cow does it all right
and then he goes to lift and he's like
oh this might be too heavy oh no and
this like I have my sulfur dioxide like
I have my monitors on like we're not
supposed to get on the ground and the
net is attached to the helicopter and
he's like what do we do and I was like
well give it another tug see if he can
get off the ground so he gives another
tug and he like gets a little bit off
the ground and I'm like okay can we head
downhill and you can get some elevation
he's like here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna use the heat from the lava
flow to give us a boost
Ride The Thermals we're gonna ride The
Thermals up with this cow underneath us
and it should give us a big enough boost
we'll have enough elevation and then
like we'll be able to get down to the
Corral system it's crazy enough that it
just might work and I'm thinking I mean
you don't really you don't really have a
choice you're like sure let's try that
so he gets this cow off the ground and
he's moving at like a good speed and
we're picking up a little Innovation and
I can see like the lava flow coming at
like 500 yards 400 yards 300 yards and
we hit the flow and it's like somebody
kicked us in the nuts we just went
straight up in the air there was so much
heat coming off the flow and I looked
down to see what was happening to the
cow because
the cow is 100 feet lower than us yeah
and this cow swings out and then as it
passes over the top of the flow all we
see is just like smoke oh no
and I thought like the head of pita is
sitting down watching the cow get
vaporized like I'm going to jail
something terrible is going to happen to
us this thing is over and we gain
elevation and we start to come out over
the flow and I'm looking down I'm like
oh God and I had forgotten that
it was pouring rain ah right and it was
soaked and all of that water like it
just instantly vaporized and it looked
like the whole thing was essentially
like on fire for a second so we come out
and like I see all the water Reaper
clear and I'm like oh thank God and come
down land that animal gets out walks
away happy as can be and then I think we
got like seven or eight more of that day
before they kind of shut us down and got
a little crazy and and we ended up
getting all 50 animals out of that place
wow and happened to be one of the most
intense moments of my life
certainly maybe not the most dangerous
but I thought we were I thought we're in
a lot of trouble for that one but it was
just such a
like viscerally intense scenario yeah
you have like these lava bombs going off
and these two flows and what a really
cool experience in that Community like
there was this celebration when
everything for months had been just a
lot of loss